but unfortunately it's not always moving  like that this is some pretty stunning  video from a camera at 215 in tropicana  and it shows just how badly behaved  impatient drivers are here in the valley  you can kind of see here that is a wrong  way driver trying to beat traffic  they're going against the grain there's  two of them in fact going the wrong way  this video was shared by clark county  traffic safety director andrew bennett  he says the ongoing nevada state police  trooper shortage which we've talked  about a lot is leading to more bad  driving there's fewer you know police on  the roads watching what's going on  earlier this year governor sysolak did  commit to filling those positions  heather